there you are with your opportunity
you've beat the odds
and you don't know your numbers set
goals you can achieve
and watch things happen because people
want to work in a winning
it's like playing for brady nobody wants
to leave the team
there is no business without cash flow
you might be able to last for a couple
of years
borrowing money getting more investors
but if you don't have cash flow
you're going to zero
everybody's a fan right thank you thank
you
you know you're probably my favorite
shark i mean you are your style is just
much
much more truthful honest like there's
no business
here there's no cash flow i'm out of
here so i like that how many of you like
him as the favorite
thank you thank you you know i i think
in business
um it's not like many other things
because there's no gray zone either you
make money
or you lose money pick one and i know
which side i want to be on
that's that's the way i look at it
that's the way i treat you kevin how
important is money
to a business because these most how
many business owners here
okay and how many of you work for a
business
okay so so
talk talk about money being important
and talking about as
it though it's important the way i look
at it is
the reason that people pursue
entrepreneurship
is not about the greed of money it's
about the pursuit of personal freedom
everybody in this room wants to be
successful
and in entrepreneurship the way you
define success is you make money
and then eventually there comes a time
in your life when you wake up and you
say
[ __ ] i'm rich i never saw it coming yeah
and
i could do whatever i want and most of
the time what people do is work even
harder
because they like what they do that's
what entrepreneurship's about it's
setting yourself free to spend your time
your day
in the things that you want to do and
the great part about it is
nobody can tell you what that is it's
only you that's the whole deal right
there
what was your first score my big my
first
um business was actually a television
production company called special event
television that made all the
intermissions
for the hockey games in the original six
teams detroit
new york boston philadelphia and we used
to run around
shooting hockey players during the week
and then we'd
send it up to the satellite for the
games on saturday nights
and that business was really successful
and i sold it and i realized wow
this is great so you start a company and
then you sell it why don't i do that
again
and that's what would you sell that
company for oh it wasn't that much i
think we started it you know with uh
ten thousand dollars i borrowed from my
mother and
i had to pay her back of course and and
the
and then we sold it was something like
four million and there was only three of
us but at that time
that's the first time i ever had any
money at all and i just plowed that into
the next deal and the next deal the next
deal and then one day
um you know we started the learning
company it was called softkey in the
beginning
and we sold that one for four billion
dollars i remember the day that happened
for what 4.2 billion i mean
yeah it was but but i have to tell you
guys something
that i'll never forget the day you know
every there was 10
founders in that company and we'd all
been together since the garage
and the next morning we were in boston
and the lawyers came over and we closed
the deal and we signed it
and i looked at everybody and said what
do you want to do
i mean we're all stinking rich what do
you want to do and they said why don't
we just go back to work
we don't know anything else and that's
exactly what happened
so so how how old how long ago was that
how old were you that was back
you know 20 years ago and and i've since
then i've had some great successes and
some catastrophic
failures that's the nature of
entrepreneurship you just don't
know but back then i was an operator i
actually
you know operated the business i don't
do that anymore i'm an investor
and i like to think that i can provide
you know guidance to my ceos about the
things
not to do because i've made plenty of
mistakes and i think that's what
experience is
you really kind of want to make it the
path of least resistance because not all
businesses are going to work
i know that and so you know i'll try a
great idea
but what the difference is and you know
this
executional skills there's a million
great ideas out there but the ability to
execute on it
and do it really hard so so
what what is the differentiator between
the the person that can execute and the
person that doesn't pull it off because
i know you just had this experience
with the 54 countries through covet but
who's the
how do you how can you look out in that
audience and say hey who here can
execute
and who is just an idea and it will
never happen well let me give you some
data which you may find interesting
because i've been doing this for almost
20 years now
the majority of the money i've made in
companies that
i was part of founding and then were
operated by another ceo
the majority has come from companies run
by women
now like i'm not trying to start gender
warfare here i'd give
money to a goat if i could get a return
i don't care
but you have to ask yourself what are
they
doing that is making these outcomes and
remember these are multiple sectors i'm
talking about insecticide companies gym
equipment companies
commercial kitchens we have a wireless
charging company i mean they're all
different
and yet the outcomes women are better
why so we did some research we said we
got to figure this out because
why don't we find out what the great
companies are doing and share it with
our portfolio companies aren't doing so
well
and what we discovered was rather
interestingly if you look at
women run companies and you look at
because you have all the data what do
they forecast for sales in a quarter
what do they achieve and then look at
the ones run by men in the case of women
they achieved their goals quarterly
ninety percent of the time okay
ninety in the case of ones run by men 65
percent of the time
but the men had sales targets 30
higher so they were really doing what i
call the testosterone stretch
really saying let's let's go for it and
only hitting at 65
of the time now why would that manifest
itself in a difference in cash flow
you got to ask that question right
here's why in a company where the whole
team consistently hits goals
the culture becomes very sticky and
nobody wants to leave
there's no staff turnover there's no
disruption in revenue there's no
disruption in accounting compliance
the team is stuck together and the ones
where you
they only hit their target 65 time
there's a lot of unhappiness in angst
particularly in the sales force
and there's staff turnovers much higher
so when we put this new policy in place
you set targets that you hit
we did this three years ago now with all
the companies i don't care if there's no
growth in your target
but if you hit the target we started to
save
lowers turnover and now in the companies
that were not doing well
cash flow is up 18
that's something you should if it's the
only thing you remember today what i'm
talking about
set goals you can achieve and watch
things happen
because people want to work in a winning
it's like playing for brady nobody wants
to leave the team
the guy just keeps winning super bowls
that's it
so so the cash flow is that just another
winning indicator for you because i hear
you talk a lot about cash flow and i
know it's really important to me
so um why and
why is it important for the audience to
measure it
let me be clear about cash flow it's the
only thing i care about
okay because there is no bit there is no
business without cash flow you might be
able to last for a couple of years
borrowing money getting more investors
but if you don't have cash flow
you're going to zero it's that simple
and i think
you have to face that reality as an
entrepreneur
cash flow is the blood of business if
you don't have any blood
you're dead so you might as well look at
it that way respect it for what it is
realize that's the only way and people
say oh that's not true what about this
what about that and i say
whatever you're talking about is
irrelevant if you don't have cash flow
yeah so so you're then how does bitcoin
relate to that conversation
so bitcoin i mean look i was not a
bitcoin guy until very recently i bought
some in 2017 but the regulator
was not and i'm in many companies that
are regulated
you know i've got an etf business i have
a lot of fintech businesses and the
regulator was very much against
even talking about bitcoin on tv as soon
as the regulators opened up in canada
and switzerland australia
england they even have etfs in canada
and they're about to get them in
switzerland now too
three three five there's gonna be
there's two more just got filed today
so it's only a matter of time before um
i'll tell you a really interesting story
about this because i only came out three
weeks ago and i said look i've bought a
three percent weighting in bitcoin
i'd already had a bunch three percent
three percent so i have a rule about
investing i never let a single stock
become more than five percent of my
portfolio i never let a
sector like energy or technology become
more than 20 percent
this includes real estate i once had
real estate up to 31 percent of my
portfolio because i love real estate
obviously it's going through some
changes on the commercial side but not
residential
but my point was when i disclosed that
i'd gone to three percent
bitcoin i'd never anticipated this would
happen
all the companies we invest in are
sustainable companies in other words we
believe in a zero carbon footprint we
think people care about that
that's why in all of our companies
that's what we do and my staff
in my operating companies and in my own
holding company are all
of that ilk of that age where they give
a [ __ ] they care
the first thing i started to get were
hundreds of phone calls from people
you know investors of mine companies
that my ceo saying
these coins you own were they mined in
china
i don't know were they mined in a way
that wasted electricity
i don't know and all of a sudden i
started saying to myself
i better get to know because people care
about that
on bitcoin and so now my new thing is
i'm starting to
invest or buy miners myself and i'm
going to just take that
virgin coin and that's the only coin i'm
going to own is it sustainable
is it mined in a country that doesn't
have sanctions on it or abuses human
beings like china does
this is the new thing coming grant on on
bitcoin you you sound
much more loving than than you i'm
kumbaya baby
i'm getting this humanity i'm totally
kumbaya
because because i've learned the
customers that it's not a marketing scam
anymore
if you're not sustainable if you don't
adhere to what customers want
as a consumer like one of my companies
is called blue land
it's trying to get rid of 50 million
plastic bottles where cleaning fluids
put in
and they crystallize the cleaning fluid
and you use a reusable glass bottle
and they ship it to you and there's a
crystal so you get your detergent
whatever it is
crystallized that thing started
it was a shark tank deal last year zero
sales it's doing 80 million a year now
wow
that tells you customers give a [ __ ]
yeah
so how important with what we just
printed in cash
i think 21 of all the u.s dollars were
printed last year
looks like they're going to load up on
another level how important are real
assets going forward
well they're real important i mean you
know
i think you got to start thinking about
things like real estate
there's a reason miami real estate is up
40 percent in the last
18 months or something because it's a
hard asset did you mention real estate
i own plenty don't worry but i've i've
trimmed back a bit on
on office commercial i'm waiting to see
how that works out
getting more into the residential side
you know that's a good revenue
you know i don't have to tell you this
like you're the guy
are you talking about apartments yeah
yeah this guy owns every apartment in
miami like he's the landlord basically
no listen you've you have to have had a
fantastic mark to market run on your
real estate it's got to be amazing it's
been just
ridiculous yeah and then what what
happens now with everybody coming down
here in the residential the home price
is going up 40
it's just gonna push into renters i'm
one of those guys i've been living in a
condo my wife is shopping for a home
she comes back with sticker prices that
i want to throw up on my shoes
like yeah the stuff is insane yeah it's
crazy but that's the that's the market
and and
do you think that continues yeah i do
i'll tell you why
we're we're going to print 1.9 trillion
dollars we're going to put it in a
helicopter
and we're going to just shower it down
on the people
now you can you can decide if that's
good or bad but that's happening as we
speak they just signed it into law in
the last 48 hours
so that's inflationary it will be
there's no question so so where does
that inflation show up is it going to
show up in job
salaries no it's first going to show up
in financial instruments you're going to
see the 10-year
probably go to percent before the end of
the year that itself is not catastrophic
but it will cause some volatility in the
markets um it'll continue to accelerate
home prices
because people would rather own a hard
asset than cash when it's being printed
i mean it's not like working so so when
that happens when the treasury goes up
and then when house housing prices go up
that means fewer people can actually buy
that house because
their salaries you didn't mention
salaries yet so the the the tenure
doesn't affect real estate until it gets
past three percent
i don't think that's happening anytime
soon so you got a ways to go before that
occurs it doesn't even affect stock
prices till it goes back you have to
think of it
when does it come competitive when do
you make a decision i'd rather own a
treasury than a stock
that's around three percent that's when
it starts to happen so we've got
we've got some time to go here but
there's no question that you know
it's going to be a different kind of
market it's going to be a little more
volatile
um you've got the whole bitcoin
phenomenon you saw a piece of digital
art
sell last night for 60 million dollars
the guy that made it you know he just
i can't even repeat what he said he
couldn't believe it and this is just
something he made on a computer that
somebody paid 60 million dollars for
that's because that person thought
this digital code is worth more than the
worthless dollars being printed
so i'd rather own that so do you
understand the nft i don't understand
what it is
what it is is a an
image that he basically made over 4 000
days
of in pictures of himself and other
things and he stitched together
in the cloud on the blockchain and the
reason that matters is there can only be
one of these images you can't copy it
it's it's locked and loaded
and what's amazing about it if the guy
that bought it sells it again
because it's on the blockchain he gets a
royalty
because he's the original creator so
this is going to happen in music too
blockchain changes everything when you
write a song and you get ripped off it
can't happen again
because when you sample the song the
blockchain goes with it
and they automatically pay you the
royalty it's amazing what's going on
so you think the artist then will go
more the
the digital way i think because he'll
get he'll get paid every time he trades
look you could have bought a picasso but
instead you bought this
think about that that's pretty crazy i
mean look it is what it is
it was a real trade it was a real us
dollar trade everybody bidding was under
40 years old
um and they were all big bitcoin guys if
you
if you have 60 million bucks it's
because you bought a ton of bitcoin
eight years ago would you tell somebody
that's done that though like
let's say somebody was in bitcoin at 500
bucks and they're sitting at 57 000
today
yeah when does a guy get off that train
here's the decision you got to make
and i this is advice that's served me
well and my mother taught me this
because let me tell you equivalent story
a few years ago my son
who was an electrical engineer was
interning at tesla
and i was i was about to go on to
halftime report on cnbc
and um tesla was downgraded that day
before all the splits it was trading at
236 dollars
and trevor said to me dad why don't you
own some tesla i worked there as an
intern and i said
i want to short that stock it's such a
joke it's a car company trading at a
ridiculous
price he said no you're the joke you
don't understand what tesla does
i work there it's not a car company it's
a
data company every time a car drives a
mile
it goes back to the server and it tells
the resolution of that road gets better
and better and better because every mile
a tesla drives it goes into the database
of mapping for autonomous cars
and i thought [ __ ] i didn't know that he
said no kidding
like you you have a ton of money why
don't you buy some of this stock
because i don't have any money so just
before i went on the air i took my phone
out and i bought a black of the stock
in my personal account not our etfs i
just bought it
then i forgot about it one day i opened
up the thing
and i was up like a thousand percent but
it was
way more than five percent of that
portfolio so i started selling it
and selling it it kept going up and i
kept selling it and selling it so you're
selling enough to get back down to five
percent
i'm yeah i mean it only recently
corrected so i bought it back up to five
percent but my cost base
is zero it doesn't matter what happens
to tesla now i made a ton of money on it
that's the trick with bitcoin you keep
it at whatever you decide i like five
percent right now i'm at three
if it goes past that i sell it down i
and my mother taught me this game she
said this way you never cry the blues
you always have cash flow
that's it you can't go broke if you have
cash so
biggest mistake you've ever made is
there a big one that stands out yeah
i've made a few seconds i remember once
i'll never forget this one it breaks my
heart
it hurts me now just to think about it
you know because i i i cry
like a baby when i lose money but the
a friend of mine started a company i
gave him 250 000
and he had a forecast it was a real
startup and i felt great i'll do it
i wasn't 100 into it but he was a friend
it's mistake number one
mistake number two was 60 days later he
comes back and says look i need another
500 000 to make this work
and my gut told me right then don't
do this do not do this it doesn't feel
right
maybe you have some stress with your
friend but 500
000 is a lot of money anyways i didn't
listen to my intuition i gave him the
500k
he went to zero 90 days later that's
750 000 please a moment of silence for
that money
because i i killed it i killed that
money
i killed it and i'll never ever ever do
that again so i don't let emotion get in
the way
you see it on shark tank all the time i
don't care about your feelings i care
about your money
you know if you're going to cry you
think i'm bad wait a little the real
world gets a hold he'll rip you to
pieces
i mean that's that's the way i look at
it what would be the best advice when
somebody comes on shark tank when
they're walking through there like
do you know i mean i know a lot of
that's you guys have some time
it is tv right yeah but if if they were
really coming here to pitch you right
now
what is there one or two piece of advice
i'll give you some good advice on this
one
first of all i'm going to tell you
something really strange that's happened
to me i've been doing this for 15 years
when they come out and they have that
moment where they're sitting on the
carpet i'm right in front of them like
they're
right in front of me and they can't say
anything because there's a guy with a
steady cam which is a camera that goes
around them
and that's that opening shot and that
takes about two minutes you don't see
any more than 10 seconds of it but they
can't say anything and the floor
director saying don't say anything
don't move and the guy with the
steadicams going around and they're just
nervous as hell and and i'm right in
front of them
so i just look at them i just look at
them i swear to you
i can tell right then without hearing
anything about their product
just looking them in the eye the way
they look back for that those two
minutes
winner loser winner
loser just the aura just the
i'm not kidding i'm not kidding and now
i really because
they can't avoid my stare i'm i'm the
guy right in front of them and i'm just
grilling them
i may never what do you see what do you
see do you know
the confidence in their eyes the ability
to take the hit
to to to to be in that stressful
environment 26 cameras all those lights
you know these these you know these
entrepreneur sharks
looking at them and not to just fold
like a leaf falling off a tree just
like almost a push back vibe
and that is the presence you need as an
entrepreneur you need to project
i'm here to kick ass i'm here to i don't
care what you
ask me i have an answer for it and i am
ready
to do business with you and you can tell
this is something
you should almost practice in front of
the mirror you have to have you have to
have
an aura of confidence an aura of
confidence
and remember even if you're in doubt
even if you're in doubt you must project
you're not i am confident i am
ready whatever hits me i'm here for it
that's what i see in the window do you
think that the the seller in this case
because they're they're selling
to you should have a specific target
or be open to all five players
you know that goes to valuation but i'll
tell you an interesting study a british
professor did he convinced
shark tank is owned by sony all right
they have it on in 23 countries
he went to sony and some of the
producers said would you let me study
the unedited tape
because i have a theory that there's a
common string
between the winners and the losers and
here's what he found and i totally agree
with this
the the deals so this is something you
should remember for whenever you're
doing as an entrepreneur it doesn't
matter if you're in shark tank this
applies to everybody
can you articulate the opportunity in 90
seconds or less
all of the companies that got funded in
all 23 countries in multiple geographies
in multiple languages all were able to
say here's my idea in 90 seconds or less
in most cases less than 60 seconds you
know
hi i'm sarah i crystallize detergent
and i eliminate the plastic bottle and i
ship it to you
to your home and we don't waste plastic
that's like 17 seconds
i get it okay so that's number one
number two
if this takes longer than 90 seconds
what is it about you
that married to this great idea can
execute
did you work in that business before did
you work for a competitor has it been in
the family have you failed before and
now you know what you did wrong
so explaining why you are the right
individual
and team to execute on the idea
now when those two come together you can
see it in the unedited tape
that all of the you know the sharks in
every country sit up and they go
oh i'm you know i have a great idea and
i have executional skills so my risk is
mitigated
i think i'm interested but here's the
killer the last one
number three you have to know your
numbers
how big is the market how fast it's
growing what are the gross margins
what's the break-even analysis you have
to be able to answer those questions
you know in the case of shark tank here
stateside if you don't know your numbers
i will personally put you in hell myself
because
you you you deserve to burn in hell
because you've made it
you have made it past 50 000
applications
only maybe 300 get considered
only 220 tape and 180 air there you are
with your opportunity you've beat the
odds
and you don't know your numbers
i mean of course you're so at that point
are you looking at the person more than
the idea
like like how much is it person and how
much idea if there was a ratio well
i'd give 70 percent to the person uh
30 to the idea because i won't invest in
uh
hot sauces there are a million hot
sauces there's always a hot sauce every
year hi
my this is my family recipe for a hot
sauce
who gives a [ __ ] like there's no way
you're ever going to make money trying
to break into the hot sauce market when
it's already completely saturated
yeah so that whole opening thing about
oh my mom's doing this the whole
story at the beginning you don't care
about any of this story right that's
just
do i care what your dog was called in
high school what
you know that you're on the cheerleading
team i mean what what does that have to
do with the investment i'm looking at i
mean that's
that's just no i know but it's such a
waste of time for you
you should be spending your time
explaining to me why i'm going to make a
ton of money
that's that's you know i was a
cheerleader that's great
but how do i make money off that yeah
like
yeah so is that person that that
personality that that we see on tv
like was that development was it this is
me
now and that's me then and i don't
change my personality
my mother taught me something really
great that i didn't really put a lot of
value on early in my career but it's a
very simple thing
always tell the truth and you'll never
have to remember what you said
right and and and what i
it's and it's very hard to do that most
people want to please
others by not telling them the truth but
that kills you in the context of shark
tank because it makes you go on a stupid
business
i'm the only one that says your business
sucks it's going to zero
you shouldn't do this you should come up
with a better idea and then they're
crying in front of me have you been
wrong on any of those where you said
no way and then they grant i'm never
wrong
there you go [ __ ] what's your mama tell
you about me
i'm just i'm just saying i'm just saying
listen at the end of the day
other investors will also choose and the
real market will choose too
but it's it's very interesting that
entrepreneurship really you have to be
able to take a few hits
you're going to fail makes you better
makes you stronger gives you callous
when you play guitar you want that
callus
you want to get that uh you know you
need that in business too
and once you're an entrepreneur and
you're you're you're infected with that
bug
you want to stay an entrepreneur it
doesn't matter if you fail a couple of
times
i would much rather invest in someone
that's felt the sting of failure anyways
i can't stand the arrogance if somebody
walks in and says you know
i'm 26 years old i've never done
anything but give me a valuation of 10
million dollars
what no i'll let barbara do that
so so you're you've mentioned your mom
three times yeah like who had the most
influence on you mom or dad
well my my original father died when he
was 37 he was an irish guy a sales guy
and my mother what's that how old were
you i was like
six okay yeah it was really tough and my
mother remarried
and my stepfather was going to
university of illinois in
champaign-urbana and i lived in
champaign-urbana
for bottom-field high school won't
forget it
there is no colder place in february on
earth
than champaign illinois i can tell you
that i love the place but i won't be
going back there in the winter ever
again
but the whole point is then he took a
job with the united nations and we
started traveling two years cambodia
tunisia ethiopia cyprus
you know every two years a different
country and that was a
huge eye-opener for me
because in every country there's expats
there's an american community there you
kind of get to know them
and we just kept moving and it really
ended up being
quite a ride um and that's sort of you
know that's
you can't you don't know what makes you
uh learn the things you learn but that
was it for me
yeah the you i read this article about
you had some
it's the meanie of money i'm not the
there were some personalities around
money or there was five
you you know what i'm yeah i know what
you're talking about tell me about that
i thought it was really interesting
yeah you know it's we we didn't plan any
of this by the way we had a yeah i know
it's called
five minutes stream of consciousness
which is always the best
the the essence of that is the idea that
you know i guess the best way to put it
is
when you form a relationship with a
significant other in your life
it's very hard to put it up this way
because it's so euphoric when you fall
in love
but actually you're starting a business
is what you're doing
and you're you're starting that business
to mitigate your risk the rest of your
life because you're going to build a
family
and what i'd like people to think about
is because i i did a lot of research in
this i've written three books on men
women and money
the number one reason that people
divorce has nothing to do with
infidelity
most marriages can survive infidelity
the reason
they they divorce between five and seven
years
and 50 of these marriages fail is
financial stress
and and what happens is one
of the pair does not have the same
objectives financially as the other in
other words maybe they outspend maybe
they
maybe they have huge credit card debts
they don't care
but if you're not in sync with each
other about money
it ain't gonna work and and that's what
i try and talk about you have to
treat it like it's the third person in
your marriage
you got to treat it with respect the
money the money yeah the money that's
the whole idea of treating it like a
vertical you have to deal with
and great marriages that last 30 40
years
you find that stability you find that a
team because you know let's face it i
mean any i've been married over 30 years
i love my wife but it's not the same
than when i met her you know it's a
whole we've gone through the whole thing
together we've been separated for two
years
but we have a family and i that's a
business you know
and i don't give money to my kids and
they're really pissed at me but i don't
care
they're they're gonna have to go figure
it out for themselves but i did
guarantee them if they ever have
children i'll pay the full freight from
birth
to last day of college because that's
what my mother did to me
fourth time his mom had a big imprint on
the ladies
she hated entitlement she hated and
entitled it
yeah she couldn't stand rich kids
that had their because when i graduated
i didn't know she was gonna do this to
me she said to me that day
from college she said listen kevin the
dead bird
under the nest never learns how to fly
and i said
what what does that mean she said
no more checks and i said you can't do
that i don't have a job she said oh yeah
i've paid all the way to this day you've
been you i've you
you've burned a lot of cash of mine and
now you're on your own
now go figure it out and i had a tough
couple of years but when i finally
was you know successful financially i
built a trust
that was designed based on her wishes
birth to last day of college
generational skipping trust and my kids
were four and seven i went home that day
that was on the learning company exit i
basically took half that doe and stuck
it in
in that generation skipping trust and i
went back and said to trevor and
savannah and they were four and seven
this is how this trust works and they
went what anyways
many years later when my son was
failing in high school he came to me one
day and said dad you know
one of his friends had a trust he said
how does my trust work i said well
if mom and i go out for dinner tonight
and we get run over by a truck
you don't have to worry because it's
going to pay for you to finish high
school
because it doesn't look like you have
the marks to get into college so you
don't have to worry about that
and he said okay what happens after that
i said well i'm dead and you have no
money
because this trust only works until you
finish school and he went
are you kidding i said no it's written
in stone and it's run by a bunch of guys
that i don't even know it's that's the
deal he went you must be kidding
i said no i'm not kidding the dead bird
under the nest never learns how to fly
is what i told him and it was it must
have been the
darkness that he felt the uncertainty
the abyss
that he faced so you want him to go to
college you insist
he went downstairs and he cracked the
books from that day on
he's now working at tesla as an engineer
he became an
engineer i thank my mother for that
that was her idea how important is
when you look at something how long are
you spending to make a decision on it is
it fast
yeah a lot of due diligence it's i have
a lot of uh
experience now and i feel i live by that
intuition
i'll tell you a story that i'll never
forget and i and i told
you i now guest lecture at places like
harvard and mit and
temple notre dame i love doing it i love
doing it and i always tell them this
story because i remember it
i don't i remember nothing from my mba i
went
my dad said to my stepfather said you
are so all you did is take
you know classes in art and psychology
and you just wanted to hang with girls
in
university and now you don't know
anything you're going to starve to death
and i went uh he has a point there so i
went
i went to business school for two years
and in the last day there was
86 people in my class and to my right
the guy that i've been sitting beside
for two years barry was his name
in comes this guest lecture last day
and it's he just looks at us like for
about a minute
and and didn't say anything it was a
weird vibe in the room he could fear
he could hear a pin drop and he finally
says to us
you people think you're so damn hot
here you are mbas that you're going to
go out there and make it happen and
everybody can't wait to see you because
you know so much
and he said you know [ __ ] you haven't
done
anything and i lean over to barry and i
say what an
[ __ ] this guy is and he went on to
explain that
the reason you become valuable in life
is you do something
you achieve something and you get
experience doing that but you're
worthless until you get that done it
doesn't matter what you learned in
school
it matters what you do that's why many
many successful people never go to
college
it doesn't matter it's really hard to
make something work in business
and i thought to myself this guy is such
a dick
now fast forward 30 years that guy is me
i i i just said that to a
this week i did the um virtually i did
it virtually
i gave the speech to the harvard
graduating class and i said the same
thing
and i said to them i hope you guys
sitting wherever you are in all these
countries
are thinking what a dick i am because
then i've done my job
one third of you are going to fail
you're just not going to make it
even though you have a hot mba who cares
the world's gonna chew you up and spit
you out
they don't care and the truth is i don't
remember a single thing
about any of what i learned in those two
years
except the people like barry i sat
beside were now bankers all over the
world so i
talk to them all the time and that guy
that guy taught me an important list it
humbled me
so so when you're looking like if if
you're going back to college today would
you be going for the education or would
you be going for the connections
connections you know that really pisses
off they keep inviting me back to guest
lecture and i always say the same thing
you're not going to remember any of this
crap but all the people
that are sitting with you that you
worked with for two years the
connections that's the
that's the why you do it because you're
not gonna remember [ __ ]
so when you're going into a room kevin
even today like are you looking to make
connections with people
this audience here or should they be
looking for how do i
connect and do business or it's business
is all about connections
business is all about respecting people
trusting people
that's why it's you know this idea of
lying to people i mean
put it in the context of the marriage
like the research i did on divorce when
i wrote the first book
when you have a a relationship of trust
in business or in marriage with somebody
and you
it's very powerful because they trust
you and they're willing to
give you the benefit of the debt when
you get caught in the lie
or you get caught cheating in business
or in a relationship
you lose 50 percent of the equity of
that relationship
forever forever and so it would be
better if
you cheated on your wife to get up in
the morning get out of bed
and call her up and say i just cheated
on you i just know
that i made a huge mistake it will alter
the relationship but at least
she'll trust that you told her the truth
you're weak in that moment
people never do that and they destroy
their relationships in business it's
worse
once you lose trust with somebody once
you do something that was dishonest with
them
word gets out real fast and you can
never get it back
what is the give him a big hand for
being here by the way
okay thank you he could be doing other
things today
two more questions sure number one why
did you agree
why did you agree to do this like why do
you do things like this
do you like this i i really i think
there comes a point
and i'm you know i'm very fortunate i
don't need any more money i
i need to keep what i've got because i
use it for all kinds of different
purposes including investing in
companies all the time
but i really enjoy giving back i like to
share
my experiences you may not agree with
them you may not agree with some of
these things
but it's food for thought that's why i
spend more and more time guest lecturing
because i know things that these kids
don't know and i want them to be
successful i'm all about
entrepreneurship
i'm always trying to get entrepreneurs
to be successful because the backbone of
the american life
is the entrepreneur that takes risks and
builds businesses
and creates jobs and i want to be part
of that that's
that's why i fight so much against waste
and government but that's a different
story
you know it's sort of this is a time now
to recover from this pandemic
and kick ass again and i think this
country is going to come out of this
thing on fire it's going to be fantastic
what is the term what does the term 10x
mean to you
10x 10x it's an accelerator it doesn't
mean money to me it means you're going
to be 10 times better
at whatever you're doing that's what i
ask people to do i say what can you do
to accelerate what can you do to be
better at what you do
people that can perform that have
consistency of performance are all
10xers
and i'll tell you a practical reason
think about it in sales if i can find
and these days i hire a lot of women
because they're fantastic sales people
and the reason i love them for what they
do is they actually hit their targets
they hit their targets and why that
matters to me is if i know they're going
to bring 2 million in that quarter
i can allocate the capital properly so a
salesperson that can actually
deliver consistently is worth gold
because you're allocating bitcoin yeah
it's whatever
you know i i'll pay my employees in
bitcoin if they want it that's fine with
me
but it's sort of a really interesting
dynamic to talk about consistency 10x
means you're a performer and you're
growing and becoming better and you're
enhancing your productivity
that's what it means to me if you like
that video wait do you see my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe
i want you to have a different mindset
when you purchase
things for yourself and let me give it
to you in a lesson that i learned from
my own mother
and i've told this story countless of
times countless times countless times